In order for our grandfather clock to keep the same time on the moon than it does on the earth,
we needs its period to be the same on both the earth and the moon
so that I can plug in the equation for the period of a pendulum for both the earth and the moon.
And fortunately lots of things cancel like the 2π here and I'm going to square both sides,
and doing that I get this nice ratio here and do a little more algebra,
I get that the length of the pendulum on the moon
should be equal to the length of the pendulum on the earth times the ratio
of the values of g on both the moon and the earth.
And plugging in our known values for g on the moon and g on the earth,
I get that the length of the pendulum on the moon should be equal to
1.6 times the length of the pendulum on the earth--great work!